[Applause]
all right
so kid cudi's wearing a dress on snl bro
the funny thing about this is like can
we just make fun of him for wearing
something stupid
like we make fun of people's clothes for
so so many different reasons but like if
you make fun of him for wearing a dress
all of a sudden becomes like gender
issue [ __ ] and it's like you look dumb
you're just so dumb like guys look dumb
in things that cut off right here and
then your little
titty fat on the side underarm pit fat
is hanging over the dress you look
stupid
yeah you look stupid yeah so we're gonna
make funny for looking stupid
it's not a bigger [ __ ] issue we don't
have to go all dave chappelle on it and
be like oh what is society is making you
i understand you like kurt cobain maybe
you want to give a little homage to him
so you wear a dress he wore a lot of
different [ __ ] things but if you want
to wear a dress that's fine
then i was like didn't you already pay
homage to him at the cardigan you going
how much did you love kurt cobain not as
much as he loves attention
you know what you're doing bro you're
getting the attention and then don't
[ __ ] cry about it if i'm a little
nausea i'm a little tight like bro you
can't let me have two more weeks on my
video for you
[ __ ] said we squash gay energy you
thought you was gay
yeah i'ma show you gay oh look at that
look cute though a little smile on his
face he happy in a dress
the dress is off-white it's made by
virgil yeah of course
allegedly yeah now let me show you that
it's a it says off-white on it actually
it's a corny dress it's a wack dress
it's corny like you just look stupid nah
real talk if you don't have that off
white on you you get that [ __ ] at
t.j.maxx for your niece that's what i'm
saying
it's like you're dead you're gonna rock
a dress at least yeah
i'm gonna say something objectively and
you know that i'm critical of kanye yeah
the kilt that he wore and i'm scottish
yeah you're scottish bro
it was flames that was kind of dope that
heavy leather yeah
kilt that [ __ ] was fire okay now i'm
sure i've clowned him tons for
appropriating my culture
and i did probably say that i don't
really care if you appropriate culture
but
it's nice to point out when that happens
the other way um
why can't we have hawaii uh appreciation
month
what is it white people history month
yeah why isn't there a white history
month right
why can't we have a white lives matter
white people love that argument bro
yeah and you know the funny thing is
that white people i know this because
i'm white like we don't even care about
being white that much
like amongst white people we never talk
about being white we never have any
conversations about being mostly you
don't there's a small percentage
that are really intuitive yeah so like
your foot fetish
i mean there's like a percentage that's
foot fetish there's a percentage of this
white fetish i guess
i i i just feel like they don't even tap
that much into that
like i feel like they're probably more
religious than they are that like show
me to white people
we love being white and nothing else uh
everyone
at the capitol i you would think no but
they also
now he's he's saying this is what y'all
are debating is white the most important
thing or is the most important thing
trump queueing on whatever
what's their biggest i like thing i
identify with do i identify as and take
pride in i'm white
or do i take pride in i'm stopping
pedophiles
i don't know trump take it check it
check it like this check it like this
there are white people that don't really
care about being white
but that don't like black people okay
they don't like you for your blackness
they just don't care about their
whiteness
they might be italian as [ __ ] you know
what i mean they might be like irish
they might have their little thing that
they identify with
but they don't really care about being
white i've never met to this day in my
entire life i met a lot of whites
that like have valued whiteness it's an
illusion unless it's in wrath
it's inlet if it's in rap okay go if a
white rapper succeeds then i'm like nice
dude oh yeah
yeah i'll be loving the chart oh yeah
like white basketball players like jason
williams
that's the only time you ever proved for
someone for doing something and they're
white you know i mean
knowledge or whiteness as if it's in
something that white people don't do
good athletics or hip-hop
yeah yeah white rap you're like nice
dude nice to see yourself
deflected white guy running the 100
meter dash dude i'm always rude for that
i'd be rooting for him he always loses
you got to watch the race like this
all the way over here you watching this
guy stumble through the 50-yard line
come on
greek you're tying his shoes and yeah so
[ __ ] chet hanks come on run bro
shout out to chet white boy summer um
i guess what i'm saying is like the a
lot of times when you see this like
white pride [ __ ] i think it's [ __ ]
because it's
they don't really feel it they're just
being reactionary yeah okay it's just
backlash
yeah but cool i'm not saying that they
don't hate y'all
no but they don't love them for that
reason yeah they like when i see black
pride i'm like oh they're
they're trying to really make a movement
to be
proud of who they are as a race right
black people are going we need to be
proud of ourselves we need to stop
looking at ourselves in the way that
people who hate us look at us yeah
it is a pride movement you're not
denying that there's white supremacists
out there
there's so many white supremacists out
there but most most races
yeah i'm not talking about the little
like groups of like kkk and [ __ ] like
that i'm talking about like the average
racist or the average like
i just think those groups are a little
bit bigger than you
here's here's what he's saying here's
what i think he's saying you know
malcolm said
uh black people aren't racist they're
reactionary racists yeah where like
white people are racist toward them so
their race is bad
people aren't people we're reactionary
like white supremacy's like reactionary
pride where like
they see you guys being proud and they
kind of don't like you so like you know
what i'm proud of me too
let me take it out thank you for
communicating that better than i could
ever [ __ ] do
let me give you an easier one to to
digest also because
with a racial component it's just so
difficult because we all have these like
visceral
memories of racism so it's hard to
remove ourselves but remember the
straight pride parade
yeah that's just reactionary there was a
straight pride parade that they were
trying to do i think like up in boston
or something like that
straight people we don't have straight
pride yeah like we're not going yo you
straight
yeah yeah me too we love [ __ ] but
we don't sit and go god we need a flag
for how straight we are or any of these
things
we j it's just a bunch of we it's just a
bunch of straight people who are losers
right
who are seeing gay pride and they're
like well why can't i be proud of myself
being straight
and then reacting in a way to antagonize
ain't not really about that life unless
it's a straight drag queen then i'm like
let's [ __ ] go talk to me on that one
that's what it is man it's like the
white rapper
you see a straight dragon straight drag
queen killing it you're like let's go
that's my people
who's a straight drag queen i don't
think they exist oh okay cuddy yeah get
cuddy let's go
he's dressed in a dragon he's
appropriating
he's a drag king dawg queen that's a
drag
king i mean do y'all care about this
[ __ ] like
i don't i don't care i just do think
it's interesting like when
depending on race what you do even if
it's the objective
same thing like the reaction's just so
different like a post malone did the
same exact thing he wore the same dress
as like an homage to kurt cobain the
same exact
uh-huh thing and nobody cares he got a
headline
where did he do it it was like some big
like uh festival thing or whatever like
it's not snl but still like
just doesn't get headlines but like a
black dude doesn't it's like yeah he
wore the dress
like he did the thing it's just it's
interesting
yeah i'm sorry it's the same thing as
like the it's the chet hanks effect
like any time you see someone acting out
of character for your stereotype of them
it's gonna generate attention so like
chet hanks is supposed to be tom hanks
he everything about tom is supposed to
be chet yeah that's tom's son why would
you not be exactly like tom
and then to see him get like twerked on
by jamaican [ __ ] you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on here this is
not tom hanks this is attention
and kid cudi is supposed to be a rapper
if you don't know anything about him if
you know him you're like oh he should
definitely be in a dress but if you
don't know anything about him you're
like you're a rapper
yeah why aren't you doing tough rapper
[ __ ] also you're black
right there's a masculinity attached to
blackness especially with males
right so like which creates the comedic
juxtaposition
uh with them being in dresses right it's
funnier to see the super masculine
person address if you take
thor and put him in a dress it's funny
because he's not supposed to be he's
hyper masculine
right and we have that outlook on black
males
which is unfair to you guys maybe we
should look at you a little more
feminine mm-hmm
would you like that no we do we do we do
ourselves as well
but sure but and also you can go back
and like
what are like the cultural uh you know
what are the cultural like impulses that
create this like
you grow up in a neighborhood that's a
little more tough you gotta act a little
more tough and
survive in that neighborhood you're
taking advantage of it right um also
like media coverage saying like black
people are more dangerous or whatever
and so you paint them as more masculine
and more aggressive
like that 100 so yeah he's playing into
that to get attention good go for it get
the attention but we're still going to
make fun of you still going to get these
jokes bro
you're a dude in a dress yeah like you
get made fun of him bro can't get made
fun of
come around the block wearing a dress
what do you think we're gonna say oh
that's off-white
all right when that [ __ ] come out you
know
like no you're gonna get these jokes i
get jokes every single
week for wearing short pants i don't
know what happens
still haven't brought the shirt up
that's true you haven't heard him back
yet
oh my gosh i'll be honest with you i'll
be honest with you i think it was
affecting views
i think it was affecting you advertisers
are gay i think advertisers were getting
nervous i got a couple calls from blue
chew they
they were concerned bro they were
concerned i was like we need you to cut
that [ __ ] off
fans were ordering too much products
like a jerk off
that's what was happening that might
have been what happened pants are just
like you're dressed you know what i mean
it's like man he wore that he wore the
pants
that's sad when you see a white man
wearing the pants you know
you